the secret to taking radical action is  to not judge yourself for the imperfect  action that you're taking this is the  problem that so many entrepreneurs have  is you you have great ideas you have  these moments of inspiration where a  great idea comes to you it's like i  could do that and and it's heartfelt and  it's purpose driven and you want to have  an impact and it's it's of service to  your community it's going to help your  family it's it's good right you're good  you've got great ideas that can then  spread more good and you're ready to  take radical action the problem the  problem is  you're worried that your first step is  not going to be perfect